数井目でずっと声が犯すんですねもう今回こちらとでください
md をより楽しむための睡眠用うどんはいこちらどうですか睡眠用のうどんでござい
ます食べれるのでしょうかあのなんかネットで見てるんですけど3民謡のうどんなマジ
で寝るみたいなデルってそもそも何って話なんですけどもうちょっとことをよくわかん
なかったんですけど人気してみて約するといまからの3か月以上かかるみたいな感じで
僕もようやく届いだけたくなる
ですけども早速上げていこうと思います有働を傷つけない程度でまいります
大変の前あっ
これや2いけないやつがこれが絶対傷つけちゃいけないですねそれで開封動画を止め
ます
もうまず穴開いてないよねちょっとこれだと3ヶ月待ったんだからねそれが本当 new
ドームですごいすごい
4中身はもう何も入ってないですねっ
細かい情報などういうことなんでしょうなんだこれまず情報がなさすぎてわからんのだ
から
なぜかうわず1回をられ3世界最大にでかいうどんですね助け見た目は調布どんなん
ですけどもなんだこれ
一応説明書入ってましたちょっと読ませていただきますまずすごいほらちゃんとうどん
あーなんか組み立て方があるみたいですねおーすごいすごいすごい
まあこれ結果的に言うと食べれないですねなんか真っ暗とかほとんどがそういう役目の
うどんらしいです奴氏ねこんな感じでネルっぽいですねえっかええなぁ何この寝方ああ
なぜならすごい論なきゃいいですねかっ
a 丼もうかけうどんになってるからすごいなんか色んな用途があるらしいですねこの
うどん a 4ならネットで見たんですけどもすごいねやすいらしくて超売れてる
らしいんですよ
すごいって言って3ヶ月また部どんなんで結構あのマジで楽しみなんですけどちょっと
今眠いんで早速見てみようと思いますかも
[音楽]
あのん
最近はここで寝てますちょっと本気で寝ると着替えてい
も jal から2品選んでるんでお願いしますよしエネルギー満々のマントるー
歩いで早速これでみようと思いますやばいこれすごい
候補べ凄い凄い本当に安いんですけどめっちゃれてるって聞いたからため汗んだろう
なぁ
聞いてみたものをよくは残土はこれはこれ何か誰か洗濯ネットが有働アナ時はこの選択
でトップから c ですっぽい
その後二度と洗濯ネットを見た者はいなかったんでこれは乱れ防止用帯
なんか普段何かうどんが似てる時に見られるかもしれないんでどんどん乱れ3なところ
に ob を作っておいてくれてる動画見られないようになるらしいですねこれ待っ
てるでしょ
ねこれ本当に安いんかななんかちょっと今一番を目指したら僕わかんないんですけどね
年の金なのでなぁこんな不動みたいな睡眠容疑ではねられた思わんけどな
制作そうですかけうどんかけうどんしてみましょう公約て
付
ほんとからこれこれで寝るのウソでしょいやじゃこれじゃ寝れんですよこんな札を
かけると見ないでねれるわけじゃなく
にゃんてるけど全然 a オレ今かかってないよねちょっと来てほしいな
あっはなんかめっちゃいいは何がいいかというとなる2期生がめっちゃいいんですよね
目が普通ふとん店なんか絶対が今後ちょっと嫌な感じ
熱くなっちゃうんですけどもこのかゲートなる通気性が良いから落ち着く安心感がある
感じがしますあっいっちゃいいけどんち
終わりだから続いてこの枕ですねそれを使って寝るのはヤバいところをしておおすごい
すごい
うん情報へやばい manx 鋭爪の枕も柔らかいしてストン壁てる気もするしこの
まだ決まってるんでも出来るって言う
[音楽]
これすごいは神かこれ神か嫁なんかちょっとと黒の最終状態になってますけどねこれ
いいですね
いろんな音方があるのがまたいいですねあーこれいいわ上号ヘギョ税
[音楽]
てっきり食べれると思ってたよくできてるなあこれ r こういうからこれでね親凄い
なって思っ坪以下月8日に翼飢えてるらしいですヨカーンと便利なのはなんかこう寝
てる時って
スマホ触りたいと切ってスプーンから手ぇ出さなきゃいけないじゃないですかそんな時
もこう
にゅっと出せるらしいですか寝てるだが暑いなんて思ったら足だけこうやって
言って出すともう涼しいみたいなようなすべてにおいて最強の寝具らしいですよこれ
それに値段は16,800円まぁちょっと注文したらいつ届くんだろう
えっ
まって今注文皿12月下旬に届く機会でありますもう今山から結構すぐ来るかもしれ
ないでねこれ
俺の3ヶ月返せ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ